em curicó uma história pode transformar
vidas
eu sou uma contadora de histórias e hoje
eu trago duas histórias que mudar a
minha forma de pensar agir e sentir
eu vi uma jovem ela criou uma família de
classe média
aos 27 anos ela sentiu necessidade de ir
à procura de trabalho e não de emprego
eu digo sempre não procurei trabalho e
emprego procurei trabalho
esta jovem foi trabalhar para um café
sem perguntar e precisava
não tinha necessidade não mas ela foi
aprender a lidar com pessoas
estrada da vida social mais baixa foi
aprender a receber ordens foi aprender a
limpar o chão ela chegava como turista
deixava o motorista na esquina e não
cansava o sobrenome dela ela trabalhou
muito tempo como servente
mas ela tem um problema que ela
trabalhava nos 33 andares
ela tinha fobia andar do valor do fundo
sempre tocava quando eu ia pedir ela
nunca teria porque havia sempre alguém
pretender mais um belo dia toca treino
ainda moça nem pensar não é comigo tem
treino é comigo só que não havia solução
ela tendo telefone e ouvi uma voz dizer
eu queria ter um café para o 11º 11º meu
deus você está chegando ainda cuidava
escadas bom trabalho é trabalho ela
teria que respeitar
ela chega à sala da senhora na nokia
estavam a secretária
uma senhora vestida toda a executiva ea
cadeira virada quando a senhora fira ela
simplesmente olhou e disse uau
quando eu crescer quero ser
e assim era bis com daqui a seis meses
eu quero estar na mesma posição que a
senhora está esta jovem despertou o
espírito empreendedor nela e passar de
seis meses ela já estava sentada numa
secretária e uma cadeira pelo alto como
empresário
segundo a história dos jovens
o carlton e constantino era de família
humilde perderam o pai muito cedo e eu
acreditava que aquilo não era não era um
estado de vida da pobreza não fazia
parte deles que eles tinham pés mãos e
cabeça para pensar que o carlos local
tudo vira pra constante diz constantino
e que tal se fossemos procurar trabalho
que tal você fosse procurar trabalho
por sorte uma senhora simpatizamos com o
jovem e deu trabalho para vender e se a
musas estes jovens têm onde estudar
acordavam cedo iam buscar os seguranças
iam vender ea escola sempre a mesma
coisa
acordava rendeu os seguranças e ou
vender ea escola só com um belo dia o
caldo filhas para o constante diz
constantino eu acho que nós podemos
fazer muito mais e quintal
que tal a gente aprender a fazer as
eu gosto de vir o qual tem de
se machucar o tom
nós acordamos cedo como é que a gente
vai fazer isso não vamos sacrificar os
vamos acordar às 5 da manhã
assim foi eles começaram a acordar mais
cedo ainda e foram aprendendo a fazer
chego sachs
mas como a vida é cheia de surpresas o
joão foi contratado por uma outra
empresa ea senhora não sabia os meninos
eo mais cedo aprender a fazer xixi e
musas ela chama os jovens e diz assim
olha infelizmente já não tenho mais
trabalho para vocês eu já não tenho quem
faça chegou
jovens com muita alegria no rosto
disseram nós sabemos fazer este musas
nós subimos fazer isso era como assim
como vocês sabem não nós aprendemos tudo
o tempo todo com joão é fazer xixi moças
o que eu aprendi com estas duas
histórias uma não importa onde é que tu
vês quem são seus pais que tipo de vida
que leva as suas condições financeiras
que tu tens mais de estabilidade e do
pode criar sua base
segundo tudo que a gente faz é
necessário que a gente tenha sacrifício
todos nós temos sonhos todos nós temos
desejos mas queremos olhar para o desejo
não queremos olhar para o sacrifício e
eu pergunto até que ponto essa que faria
qualquer coisa que o fato atento de
respeitar a um trabalho
muitos de nós entramos pro muito
trabalho mas de seguida começamos a
criar histórias os outros os outros e eu
com estas duas histórias e eu te
transformar numa palestrante contadora
de histórias
muitos disseram me que eu mude vai ser
para estradas e nem sequer fez o cloud
uau eu vi isso por muito tempo porque
como é chamado vai ser palestrante não
fez curtas gaúchos
eu disse 'não quer fazer curso do code
porque o ponto uma história eu sou
contadora de histórias
antigamente nós conhecemos histórias de
geração em geração de tribos etnias
culturas através de uma história apenas
diziam era uma vez à volta da fogueira
nós ouvíamos para uma fez os nossos avós
eles diziam que era uma vez os nossos
pais antes de nós dormirmos que diziam é
uma vez as nossas avós
antes do casamento elas diziam ei era
cuba fez nas escolas ensinavam era uma
vez e eu pergunto qual é a tua história
qual é a tua história vemos todos contar
histórias por cada vez na história as
ações são salvas vidas são transformadas
e uma das minhas histórias com o
palestrante já salvou uma jovem que
cresceu e se dar por que ela achava que
já não tinha como viver com o marido a
agredia e psicologicamente fisicamente à
frente dos filhos ela achava que já não
podia mais
os próprios amigos fugir dela porque ela
sofria de depressão aguda e disseram que
não não conseguimos conviver com ela e
ela ouviu falar que havia alguém que
contava uma história e ela começou a
seguir a palestrante contadora de
histórias
os os amigos querem conhecer porque
apenas perguntam como fizeste como
transformar eu disse apenas
contei uma história apenas digo era uma
vez
era uma vez eu sou contadora de
histórias e tu qual é a tua história
[Aplausos]